in the age of social 15 minutes of fame
can last for 15
years which is really interesting so i
would argue that the half-life of fame
today is increased so if you have your
viral moment if you have a ken bone
moment right like the
red sweater guy from the undecided voter
right
once you kind of blow up you are there
so for cameo
it's not just all the people that are
famous now or
all the famous that will be famous it's
all the people who have ever been famous
who can be in that subset of people that
can be on the platform
and that is where i think cameo can
start going where you have these folks
that
maybe they start a little less famous
but they start building their
product market fit in their boot and
then they get a new like
ideally for you like you have some like
lower list celebrities
get booked on a big hit show booked on a
big movie grow their career and
cameo can ride that wave with them
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks it's
thursday
you know what that means it means your
co-host zach grauman
is hosting the next episode of the
future of
and today's episode is on the future of
celebrity and we've got
someone i've known for a while whose
career i've been able to
admire from a distance and finally got
him to come on the podcast stephen
gallanis
founder and ceo of cameo
is joining and we talk about those who
not use cameo it's pretty cool it's a
way
for anyone to find a celebrity
an athlete an actor superstar musician
you name it
to get these individuals these people
you love
to send short videos to other people you
love
so you can send a video of stanley from
the office
giving a shout out to your best friend
it's a pretty uh
amazing tool they're growing like a weed
just got valued at a billion dollars
like this company is really really
fascinating and redefining how we
interact
with frankly famous people and
redefining that relationship between
talent and fans so i thought it was
compelling
and worthy to have him on the podcast so
we talk about
not only his journey as being an
entrepreneur but where this is going and
how this is
going to affect how we consume all sorts
of media
in the years to come so you're not gonna
want to miss this stephen golanis
founder of cameo joins yang speaks the
future of celebrity
starting right now
[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen it is my
privilege to welcome
world-class entrepreneur actually world
class we used to just say entrepreneur
now i can say world class
world-class entrepreneur co-founder and
ceo
of cameo stephen golonis mr glonass
welcome to yank speaks the future of how
you doing man
thanks for having me zac glad we snagged
you man we uh
you've just been doing a a big pr tour
um cameo was just value valued at a
billion dollars
so this this thing started from
let's call it a figment of your
imagination into something that's
employing hundreds of people
so let me say this just it's an awkward
weird question but now you you're worth
a lot of money on paper
as is your company what's how you what's
the like the emotional feeling right now
that you have and your team's having
well uh first off zach again thanks for
having me
uh you know as an entrepreneur starting
a tech company
kind of the ultimate dream that people
have at the beginning
is here to build a billion dollar
company right to build a unicorn
um you know everybody it takes just as
much work to build
a company like that that's worth zero as
is
a billion in subways um you know like
for every entrepreneur out there right
whether you
um are promoting parties like i did in
college
or you have a t-shirt business or you
have a small
uh hot dog stand like in new york city
you're working just as hard so it's it's
really about finding a business model
that
can continue to compound and not just
have your efforts be
you know the thing that's driving it
forward but like you know finding
network effect which can mean that
the more people that are working on your
dream the more people that are
entering in our case this marketplace
you know it can just compound in a
really big way and that's what's
happened
um the thing that's really interesting
and and i've been reflecting on this
you know since the announcement came out
while
uh building a billion dollar company is
certainly like a dream of every
entrepreneur
i would actually use the analogy that
it's really
similar to being the number one overall
draft pick
in the nfl draft right so every kid that
picks up a football
dreams that one day roger goodell will
hold their jersey up and they're gonna
have to take a picture
but you know only two percent of number
one draft picks make the hall of fame
right and fifty percent of nfl draft
picks uh you know don't
last in the end in the nfl for over five
years
so the journey is very
much like while we've achieved like a
step on it you know a cameo we're trying
to build a hall of fame company
we're trying to build something that's
enduring that a hundred years from now
could be
in the smithsonian if they have uh an
exhibit on like tech companies that came
out
so i still believe we're probably in the
top of the second
inning for what we're doing here and um
this was just one necessary milestone
towards
you know really building a truly
enduring company
uh i spoke like a true frankly leader
which i know you are
um and i agree with you look i
put a lot of blood sweat and tears
building a non-profit which i'm really
proud of and has done great but
nowhere near you know that type of
valuation so i agree with you there's
there's
it's not just the effort it's the
execution and the idea and
the community building or inspiration
around it so let's let me back up a bit
so
um for those of you listening guys i
knew steve in college
and um his nickname was
um mr mayor which i think you even had
in high school a little bit
um and i don't know how to explain it
guys like
so we went we went to duke university in
in durham north carolina and
it's a it's not a 6 000 undergrad is
like 10
000 with with grad school kids it's
relatively big
but everybody knew glonis and it was
because of these random
he was always doing a different venture
and the big one was
uh throwing parties in college there's
spartan entertainment
and he was known for wednesday night
shooters night which shooters is a
famous bar at duke it's like a western
themed bar and it's a piece of crap
um but wednesdays nothing was going on
and steven's like well look if i can get
people to show up on wednesday
and they pay five bucks at the door can
i get a cut that sort of thing i'm
pretty sure that's how it started so
talk to me about um your
entrepreneurial journey because to me i
always like to consider myself a natural
builder but
nowhere near it seems like it was in
your dna probably even younger than
college i imagine so tell us about you
and your background bit
it's funny thinking back to the spartan
entertainment days but
you know in many ways when people ask me
what you know i majored in at duke like
i say entrepreneurship we didn't have a
major for
business or entrepreneurship there but
that's what i did
you know that that that's what i spend
my time doing and
you know for those that didn't go to
duke between
2006 and 2010 this was a really
interesting age where facebook was brand
new
um you know zach and i were the first
grade of
college students that actually had
facebook for throughout the entire
day of our college experience and back
then you had to have the
edu address to even get onto the network
so i remember
you know when i was a senior in high
school people would like apply
early to a safety school and put the
deposit down just to get the
edu address so they could join the
facebook at the time
it was that pretentious and exclusive it
was a big freaking deal
and um one of the things that you know
we
noticed that was really different from
for people like zach and i
versus any other generation that had
ever gone to college was that we had
this thing facebook
and we were connected with every single
person that we met
in in many ways like we're still
connected right like you know all those
people you friended from your freshman
year dorm on facebook
you know they've been following
everything that you've been doing with
your charity with
you know with the yang campaign so in
many ways like we had this built
in distribution network and we kind of
came along at the right time
back then bar owners were not able to be
on facebook so
back in the day when you know you
created a facebook group and people
joined and you created an event and
people
showed up uh me and a guy named zach
maritas who's another
entrepreneur who was a senior when i was
a freshman
and is now the ceo of a very successful
tech startup back in durham called
teamworks
zach and i had the idea to start
throwing
non-affiliated parties because well zach
and i were friends we were in different
fraternities so if sigma nu was throwing
a party the delta cigs wouldn't show up
if the atos were throwing a party the
saes wouldn't come
but zach and i decided to create our own
branded parties that were unaffiliated
and slowly but surely everybody started
coming so it didn't matter what
fraternity you were in it didn't matter
if you were in a fraternity it didn't
matter if you were
in band or a football player like you
came to our parties
and um and over a four-year period we
took
uh starting with one event which was uh
putting beer pong tables
out uh on wednesday night at like the
big
bar on campus that used to be closed and
offering three dollar pictures
and taking the cover charge um we ended
up
having over 17 000 college students in
this facebook group
and started a variety of businesses uh
off this key asset so we had a college
boxes
business for a couple years we had a hot
dog stand at one point
uh we did dj equipment and t-shirt
rentals and
venue bookings like you name it zach and
i were doing it
and i think it really gave us uh our
first
taste of entrepreneurship and for zach
you know that capital from spartan
entertainment was a lot of the seed
money that started his business and he's
continued to do that
uh today and like i said it's a very
successful business
and for me uh this you know taste of
entrepreneurship was something that i
could never
fully get out of my mouth and when i
ended up leaving durham
and going to be a trader for a few years
or working at linkedin
like i did other cool things but that
entrepreneurial bug
kept you know kept nagging at me and
i really believe that like the three
percent of people on earth
who have that mutation in their brain
that makes them like a true entrepreneur
uh it's almost impossible for those
people to to do
great like the best work of their lives
if they're working for somewhere out
someone
someone else and i would put myself in
that case and uh
and for me you know cameo has been
something that's really
at that guy point for me ikigai is this
japanese philosophy
that believes that your true life's
calling is the intersection of
what do you love to do what are you
great at what does the world need and
what can you ultimately get paid for
and it has to be at that like pure
intersection point
and you know zach i'll ask you uh you
know you've known me for a long time
like is this bit is is the fact that i
started this business surprising to you
oh dude not not at all um you've got
these
smartest minds in the world in many ways
at duke university
and they're all like
slaving away at their econ exams and
their chemistry exams this thing and
you're out there throwing parties
which seems like a joke um but on the
other hand you're learning
10 times more like because like you're
negotiating deals and you're going to
contracts and booking venues and
recruiting people and developing a
marketing plan and
like raising capital and like investing
in new businesses i figure i knew like
smart entertainment was like the tip of
the iceberg for you but i was more
surprised when you went i think you were
a trader and you worked at linkedin and
i was like
i knew that wasn't the end game either
so i was so like
um but i remember getting an email from
you
it was a survey monkey survey like hey
we've got this idea
where famous people
can get paid to facetime their fans
what do you think of these names and it
was like this long survey
a bunch of names uh cameo was one of
them if i recall but there were a bunch
of others
um nothing personal cameo wasn't my top
boat uh
i don't remember what what it was i
probably looked it up but it's fun it's
funny
we were just talking about this survey
and um
cameo wasn't on the original list
actually there were four
there were four and i will tell this is
exclusive nobody else has ever heard
this story
so i hope your listeners enjoy uh we
we hired a branding firm in miami called
vanilla shake who's incredibly talented
and we went through the exhaustive
process of like
naming and in a consumer internet
business like a name is so
critical and when we first started the
business we
we didn't know what the name was so we
were using
um well so there are two things that
happen number one my co-founder martin
uh his family businesses in the uk are
all
bearing like barren homes and barren
finance and things like that
so he wanted to call the business baron
app
and they were and and actually today
that is the legal name of the company
the legal name of the company is
baron app inc so you guys go public the
new york city stock exchange listing
is kind of barren app llc
and it's funny because we had actually
never um
we had never nobody's ever like called
us bear an app before but in the wall
street journal like
funding announcement they always use the
legal name of the business
so it was talking about baron app inc
valued at a billion dollars the parent
company of cameo
so it was just kind of interesting and
and but we knew
baron app could not be like what we
called this business
um at the time we decided to use a code
name
and we called it uh power move so pow
it was called pop project power move was
was was basically
what we called it in the branding firm
that we hired came up with three names
uh first was hero hub uh so almost like
it was like a hub to find your heroes
the second name was
thrillo and the third name was hyped
h-y-p-d
you can tell a bunch of dudes are making
this this company
we put this name out these four names
out
to all of our uh followers on
linkedin we collectively downloaded all
of our linkedin contacts
and put this survey monkey out and
unfortunately
power move won so we knew we didn't have
a great name
and some of the feedback the branding
firm personally had recommended hero hub
and for our east coasters everyone felt
that that sounded like a sandwich shop
which was you know kind of funny uh so
ultimately
we you know went back to the drawing
board and my little brother
who was working for us at the time was
like i think it should be called
cameo he's like these people are kind of
making a cameo
in your life and immediately it was like
thank you little bro
that has to be the name of course
cameo.com was not available
and seemed to be impossible to get
all the social handles weren't available
so what we decided to do is we bought
book cameo
verb in front of it yeah it made all of
the socials book cameo for a while
but for the first couple years of the
business
people just thought it was called book
cameo so that's
so that's a a little you know fun story
about
how cameo got its name i've now become
very passionate about this
and always kind of have been but andrew
was very very passionate about naming
things
um we always joke like we should write a
book or a medium post on how to name
stuff
now andrew loves naming things but he's
terrible at it and i'll tell him that to
his face
but his big thing is like when you're
doing a new project something exciting
give it a cool name
so he's always like project excelsior or
something exciting and if it's a bad
project name he hates it so he's like
yeah i have a good one
but then the second one for me on naming
is always the way to name something is
to think about how you want
others to talk about it and that is how
you give it
life so it's like the reason hero hub is
less exciting because people talking
about everything i think it's a sandwich
or like what the hell is that but
cameo sounds cool it is interesting it's
like for us we named the yang gang like
i was like i was really out of the teams
like we need a name for supporters
uh the the community building that you
guys did was absolutely fantastic you
know what you're seeing on twitter with
the blue hats right like
this is this is really really uh
next level stuff on community building
and we've tried to do the same
with uh our concept of the cameo famio
and the cameo family for us is not just
all
the people that work at the company but
it is
in the same way the yang gang it's all
the supporters right so
it's all of our customers it's every
talent on the platform
it's everyone that's ever seen a cameo
it's everyone that thinks
it's a cool idea of yesterday
i got a text a friend of mine who had
came and see me recently
was wearing a cameo sweatshirt in the
middle of times square yesterday
and someone just yelled across the
street i [ __ ] love camio
and this is like some random person in
time that's
amazing and that's you know again that
is the stuff
that um that that community can do and i
think when you have a community
that is as passionate as the one that
you guys have built or is this
passionate
is the cameo family or that we're
building it actually
just enhances the organic conversation
around your main messages you have net
promoters that are
out you know i don't know what the nps
of the yang gang is but i'm
i'm sure it's pretty high at cameo our
net promoter score of our customer base
is in the high 70s right it's up there
with the iphone or
tesla and you watch you watch when you
have a consumer brand that people are so
passionate about
it makes it outsized it gives us an
outsized amount of media attention
it gives us an outsized amount of the
conversation that's happening on social
and it just projects this aura around
the brand or the candidate or the
message that you're doing
that amplifies it naturally so um i
think naming is critically important as
andrew does
and i think activation of community is
like
the biggest superpower on earth and this
is why
when you're watching what's happening uh
with the
influencer world right now or the larger
creator economy
um you know i saw yesterday kim
kardashian
finally became a billionaire and one of
the interesting
lines in the story right was that
they asked her who's the next you know
kardashian that's gonna be a billionaire
and basically she said
we all are gonna be right like because
we've all built this
following and we all uh you know have
you know have this huge
movement of supporters behind us so
you know you can give us a product and
we can put it out there
and we have equity in that so and it
sells itself
because we have distribution with
spartan entertainment we did the same
thing so i really learned about kind of
branding
there this you know it wasn't steven's
party it was in zack's party we created
you know this whole aura around spartan
entertainment and
we started creating different businesses
and everything was branded really well
so for me that lesson started in college
for us we did what we could to apply it
to politics um and some people in
politics do really well bernie did it
really well trump does it exceptionally
well
yang does it really well um and there's
a whole bunch of reasons for it but it's
this
concept of authenticity and connection
and making people people feel far to
something but companies doing it too i
think you guys do a great
peloton's one of my favorites because
one there's that authenticity connection
between the instructor and you and
you're struggling
you're you're you're working out
together and sweating and gritting but
also
you know they have a when they do they
have an in-person conference every year
and people are best friends through this
community
[Music]
all right if you've been listening to
the show for a while you've heard us
rave about our helix mattresses
because they're awesome so helix
mattress has left the bedroom and
started making sofas and they started a
company called
all form and they're making freaking
fantastic sofas i have one in my
apartment
it's light gray it's three seats wide
it's got a little foot thingy and it's
freaking amazing what makes this thing
so freaking cool
it is so easy to customize a sofa
without like compromising quality
right so you can pick your fabric you
can pick your color you pick the color
the legs your size whether you want the
massive sectional you want the little
ottoman little leg thingy you can do it
all
they've got arm chairs and love seats
all the way to eight seat sectionals so
it's massive and they're delivered
to your home like the mattress and you
can assemble it yourself i'm an idiot
and i assembled my couch
and it feels like it's built like a rock
you get a hundred days to decide whether
or not you want to keep it which is more
than three months and if you don't love
it they pick it up for free
and give you a full refund so here's the
deal
find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
yang and all form right now is offering
20
off all orders for our listeners at
allform.com
yang so check it out we love all form
for those that like never use cameo i i
know you talk about this all the time
but
talk me a bit how it works just high
level and then
i have a bunch of like nitty gritty
questions um but let's i'll rather have
you explain it than me
if you will sure so cameo is a
marketplace where you can
book personalized video messages from
over 40 000 of the most exciting
names in pop culture athletes actors
entertainment
entertainers musicians of all kind um
you go to our website cameo.com where
you can download our app on
uh on apple or android you can browse
through
the talent um every talent sets their
own price
so today people range from zero dollars
to
ten thousand dollars uh the average
video is about 70 so it's
a lot more accessible than you know most
people would think
when you find someone you like you can
craft a 250 character message
you click submit the talent then has uh
seven days to basically take your script
and turn it into a bespoke
you know one of a kind piece of content
uh that you're either giving to
somebody else or you're having for
yourself and then they you can save it
though on your if you get in your app
you can save it and share it with your
friends or keep it forever that kind of
thing right exactly yeah the
the idea that really gave birth to cameo
was that the selfie was the new
autograph
if that is true right when when yang
shows up at some event
everybody all the supporters want to end
and take a picture with him
and then they want to put that on social
and it's kind of proof that that
happened
in a world where you can't be with him
at that time right
this is a way to take a selfie removing
location as a variable right so
by having a video message that's bespoke
that's saying what you
you want them to say and then you post
that on your instagram or you posting it
on your twitter
it allows you to have that similar
selfie experience without
meeting the person in real life and that
ultimately enables
talent of all types to impact way more
of their fans because
they're not limited by location as a
variable
i pay 150 bucks 300 bucks
50 whatever that math is and then you
guys get a cut and then the artist gets
like
80 you get 20 that kind of thing yeah we
take
25 of every transaction and the talent
makes takes 75 and they all set their
own price so
um that's and at this point the thing
that's pretty cool about the platform
is in the same way when somebody's in
new york city
looking for real estate they're going on
zillow and they're browsing
you know within a building hey here's
the two bedroom two bath
uh this one is a higher floor it's got a
nicer view it's got a different kitchen
people are going to cameo and they're
cert and they're searching people on
relative value as well
so if you love the new york knicks or
you love the rangers
you can go look at all these people and
they all have their different price and
especially for athletes like a lot of
times you know someone like brett favre
might just he was number four his old
career so he'll put a couple zeros
behind
it and be 400 but you know then you
might see
somebody like it for the chicago bears
this is a great example
uh brian urlacher and lance springs were
relatively similar players for the bears
like both
uh all pro linebackers erlacker first
ballot hall of famer
lance briggs maybe hall of fame maybe
not but like for bears fans they're seen
as like pretty much
uh equal lance spriggs is 55 dollars his
jersey number and briner lacquer's 540
his jersey number so often times
you know if you love brian erlacker
you're gonna pay up but like if you just
want a bear line
backing legend to talk to you like glen
springs is totally fine
our trust in institutions
is declining massively and
i think it's a combination of things
we're an older country so our
institution our institutions have
objectively failed in almost every
uh area you go from education to
healthcare but in 20 20 20
just if anybody expected that 2020 just
did whether it was health healthcare or
education
trusting government government or
you know voting or like whatever it is
right like every single
sacred institution uh religion
right just came under massive question
this past year
right and uh and this is actually like
tease up really well kind of like our
long-term vision
the technology we're building at cameo
thinks about that right like in a world
of fake news or a world of
deep fakes right like authenticity we
believe is going to carry the day
and we believe that it is necessary
that over the next decade we build
technology that enables
every one of the world's talents so this
could be you know an actor an athlete a
politician
to develop a personal relationship with
every single one of their supporters or
fans
right in in 10 years ago if we had
talked about that
that would have been like absolutely
impossible you know you think about
showing up at a um at a jay-z and
beyonce concert and like
looking at the hundred thousand people
in the football stadium
and thinking like wait in the future
like jay-z and beyonce could have a
personal relationship with every single
person here
and all their millions of fans around
the world no way
right but like now as we're watching you
know
products like cameo you know other
products going on in the space
you can start to believe that this is
gonna be possible
and for us that's the north star that
we're really driving towards
that's a lot of what the internet does
like cuts out the middle men and women
it cuts out this
barrier we've had with our institutions
and frankly it's sadly breaking them
down and instead of improving them but
in a way you're you're slowly but surely
getting rid of
like talent agencies like do you see
and maybe you disagree that like what do
you where do you see this fitting in
there
the you know really like simplistic
answer is yes right like yes you know to
get
um you know snoop dogg to like make a
video for some kids bar mitzvah
pre-cameo you would have had to track
down their agent to go do this
the reality is agencies are
great at being madison avenue sales
people
right they're unbelievable at connecting
you know
athletes and actors with brands they
can help negotiate their contracts with
a television network
or with the sports team or the split
with their record label like that is
what they're great at
they're great at like b to b essentially
right like so the talent to like the the
business or brand
for cameo like the b2c side
of agency is just never his work there's
a 100-year
legacy of of you know william morris
agency like
helping movie stars or broadway stars
like negotiate with their producers
but like they never figured out how do
we like connect
the talent with their fans directly
because it was completely impossible pre
facebook pre-twitter pre instagram you
know pre
uh tick-tock pre-these platforms for
youtube
so in many ways like the cameo revenue
is not replacing at all you know
any significant part of the revenue
that's coming from town agencies
it's just literally creating net new
opportunities net new surface area
by opening the direct to fan
monetization channels up for the first
time
[Music]
all right you know what an
out-of-the-box idea for mother's day is
a hello tushy bidet yes hello tushy is
still a sponsor of yang speaks and the
bidets are still
awesome it's a great idea for mother's
day because they're stylish they're
eco-friendly
they're easy to install they feel great
they cut down on toilet paper cross and
they help the environment
so hello tushy 3.0 is the champ
it cleans itself it's got this smart
spray automatic self-cleansing nozzle
is super easy to attach it cuts your
toilet paper used by 80 percent
guys toilet paper adds up and look every
hello tushy bidet attachment comes with
a 60 day risk free guarantee and a 12
month warranty so get the hello tushy
3.0
midday give the gift of a clean butt go
to hellotushy.com and get 10
off plus free shipping pretty cool 10
off free shipping that's a special order
for yang speaks listeners at
slash hellotushi.com for ten percent off
so it's hello tushy
dot com slash yang
[Music]
one of things that we did with andrew
was um the concept of product market fit
where it's like so in the really early
days
we're out there trying to make andrew a
politician
or like try and i'm taking him to
fundraisers and like dragging people
these fundraisers
and it just was like flopping right it
was just like trying to
like presenting him to the political
class and establishment they're like who
are you
what is what are you talking about right
and instead of
um making him appealing to everyone
what we did is we found the people who
thought
andrew was appealing right instead of
like we've kind of flipped it where it's
like no andrew you be you and let's find
the people that like you and grow it
and so um i'm curious
from your angle and how you're looking
at this where it's like you get on a hit
next flick show
right instead of as an actor let's say
for example or maybe an artist do the
same thing but as an actor
you got to get your next thing quickly
to stay relevant right
but in yours like sure that's helpful
but if someone's awesome on a great tv
show they can start building a fan base
through cameo
without their next big thing like like
is that the future like what talk to me
what you think about the
market fit thing so two so two things
number one
um i love what you talked about of
finding the supporter base and in the
same way
right you can imagine building the cameo
market place from scratch
and just like any marketplace you have
the cold start problem
which is you know we need to build
supply and we need need to build demand
like imagine the early days of cameo
where we had a platform where
we connected fans with their favorite
athletes but we had no athletes and we
had no fans on it right like
where do you get first do you get the
fans and then tell them
hey stay tuned like eventually we're
gonna have people to come here or did
you get the athletes and put them on and
there's no fans so they joined this
thing
they promote and they get booked and
it's just like a disaster
we we had pretty high conviction in our
case
that the supply side was going to be the
critical
side of our marketplace so we spent all
of our time
you know early focusing on supply side
acquisition so getting
athletes your musicians reality talent
onto the platform you get brett favre
then you go out and find as many packers
fans
yeah well the nice thing is we didn't
even really have to do that because
brett favre has social media right in
social media
he can send a tweet out and he's got a
million followers so all the packers
fans are already following him
so in many ways like in our marketplace
supply could get its own demand
on the same time when we were thinking
about the universe of the five
million people on earth that we think
could be on cameo
what i came up with early was a
framework for
the young kids that were working for us
or interning us that same summer
i remember drawing a 2x2 on the
whiteboard
and the x-axis said willingness from
like
zero willingness uh so think marshawn
lynch at the super bowl
right like he got fined you know like a
hundred thousand dollars
to not talk at the super bowl it's just
like every person's dream is like being
the super bowl
and he like refused to answer questions
i don't get fined whatever
all the way to like me you know at the
far end right
like i'm the founder of cameo i am
the number one most likely person in the
world to like
do a cameo video right so that's the
x-axis and then the y-axis
from like me to like justin bieber
or like lebron so my mother at the
bottom
the y-axis is fame so of course we want
people in the top right quadrant
super famous super willing we didn't
want to deal with
anyone in the bottom left not that
famous not that willing
if you get someone you know like they're
a third string you know left guard from
the
cleveland browns and you know they're
people and people no people book them
and they don't do the
they don't do the video right like
that's such a shitty experience that you
don't want that
and we made a really controversial
decision
early which uh was ex is it was
contrarian i would say
even more than controversial we focus on
people in the bottom right
less famous more willing over the top
left
more famous less willing for two reasons
number one
we believe that if thad lewis the former
duke quarterback who
you know spent seven years as a third
string backup quarterback in the nfl
bills love you bad but charged five
dollars
and does all the videos in two seconds
that's such a magical experience
we would rather have him on the platform
than tom brady
at 50 000 that doesn't ever want to do
on it
right so for us that's what we really
focus on was less famous more willing
that built liquidity it rigged the
customer experience
to to really wow them and our belief was
if you paid
fi if you paid five dollars to have a
great experience with dad lewis
in the future you know when we got andre
read on or we when we get jim calion if
you're a huge builds fan
you know for 200 or 500 bucks like you
know cameos great and you know what to
expect
and that'll work and that's that was a
big part for us you know in the age of
social
15 minutes of fame can last for 15 years
which is really interesting so i would
argue that the half-life of fame
today is increased so if you have your
viral moment if you have a ken
bone moment right like the red sweater
guy from
the undecided voter right like that
guy's on cameo and he gets booked today
for like
15 minutes of fame because he blew up on
twitter and now he has an audience
and even long past he's you know his
time of being
like in the spotlight on cnn every day
like
he now has a network that he can use as
distribution for anything else that he's
doing because people tend not to
unfollow people except for like very
extreme
grievances so once you kind of blow up
you are there so for
cameo it's not just all the people that
are famous
now or all the famous that will be
famous it's all the people
who have ever been famous who can be in
that subset of people that can be on the
platform
it's this interesting concept of of a
platform of a personal platform and that
is where i think cameo can start going
where you have these
folks that maybe they start a little
less famous
but they start building their product
market fit in their boot and then they
get a new
like ideally for you like you have some
like lower list celebrities
get booked on a big hit show booked on a
big movie grow their career and
cameo can ride that wave with them if
you want a graphical
representation of where we have product
market fit
turn over the back of a one dollar bill
and you know
you can picture the pyramid with the eye
on top right
cameos product market fit for you is
talent the second that you have your
first
like you know you get on your first
episode of some show or you have your
first song
and it continues all the way till the
top of the pyramid where you become like
the most famous
people on earth some of the most famous
people on earth will continue to
stay on cameo during their rain in the
sun
but there's other people that get so
famous where
and just you know most talent are
motivated by three things
money fame and love right but there are
some people
who become so famous and they become so
beloved
and they become so rich that they don't
need more fame they don't need more
love they kind of want to be left alone
but the thing that's interesting is that
this is dynamic people are constantly
moving up and down that pyramid
and there's other people who were the
most famous people in the world
and then there's suddenly not anymore
right you think of you know how big
brett favre or ray lewis were and you
know they're always going to be legends
they're hall of famers
or charlie sheen right charlie sheen was
the highest paid actor in
in television you know for for a long
time
and then you know social media because
that 15 minutes of fame can last for 15
years it gives them a platform where
they can go forever
so there's also this like this this
this right edge of the pyramid which is
like your nostalgia point
where people like you know james van der
beek or you know someone from
like buffy the vampire slayer like these
shows that you loved as a kid
right like you might care to hear more
about them
than uh justin bieber right now because
they had some like meaning to you
growing up
[Music]
all right you know what time it is here
on yang speaks we are always
sponsored by athletic greens i freaking
love athletic greens i use it all the
time
every day wake up open the blue pouch
pour this
green powder into half a glass of water
mix it up and drink it and it's
wonderful
it makes me feel better i don't eat that
well in the pandemic and this makes me
feel like i'm covering all my bases and
that's because one scoop
of athletic greens which taste great
contain 75 vitamins minerals
whole food source ingredients including
a multivitamin multi-mineral probiotic
green superfood blend and more they all
work together to fill nutritional gaps
in your diet increase your energy and
focus which it does it does increase
your energy and focus a bit
and aids with digestion and supports a
healthy immune system all
without the need to take multiple
products so here's the deal visit
athleticgreens.com yang and join health
experts athletes and health conscious
go-getters around the world
who make a daily commitment to their
health every day simply visit
athleticgreens.com yang get your free
year supply vitamin d and five free
travel packs today with your first
purchase
that is our deal for you five free
travel packs and a free year supply of
vitamin d
at athleticgreens.com
[Music]
you're growing like a weed the pandemic
accelerated you're already
pretty strong growth frankly um
and you've got if i get this number at
least over
200 employees working for cameo right
and they've been most of them hired in
the past couple of years i'm assuming
um but i i want to say this and i think
you agree
hiring 200 people in a year is [ __ ]
hell
and no one can do it right and there's
no playbook on it and you're breaking
everything
from the outside looking in it always
looks a lot easier right like
you know you took a survey you didn't
think about cameo for a couple years and
then all of a sudden oh [ __ ]
you're in cnbc and it's like a billion
dollar company
but like the thing the devil is in the
details
and finding product market fit is one of
like
five things that is a ceo you need to
absolutely nail
hiring is interesting and because i
worked at linkedin i think i have like a
pretty unique perspective on it
at linkedin we used to pride ourselves
being the best hiring company on earth
because we had every resume on earth
right no other company has every resume
but even so at linkedin they found that
in in on a three year on a one year
basis
for an individual contributor employee
one-third of people that they hired
didn't work out after one year
right one-third one-third i know that
this is also the case at companies like
amazon
where at amazon they give they find that
i think it's
72 percent of the people that
um that they extend a internship like a
pre
uh graduation internship for that
they'll give a full-time offer
so somewhere between 25 and a third
of the people that you hire even if
you're best in class
right and your linkedin your
amazon your apple your microsoft these
are hall of fame
companies right like you are gonna
screw up hiring somewhere between 25
and a third of the time and you just
have to be okay with that
in the and it's interesting i just did
an interview on cnbc talking about this
i don't think it's inherently a lot of
people say oh making mistakes is great
it's like inherently
i don't think making mistakes is
inherently valuable at all
but what i think is valuable is to
quickly address the mistakes that you
made
so so one of the things that we do at
cameo that's really interesting
is we've rolled out something called the
mvp performance process
and while we negotiate somebody's
like if you're gonna come work for me
and actually be on the executive team
like it's customary in startups to
negotiate equity and
negotiate cash and you know different
things like that but i actually make
them negotiate their a plus
20 you know their a plus one year
performance review so if you were gonna
come work for me i would say zach
you and i are gonna take a google or
google spreadsheet or google doc
and we're gonna write out what does your
a plus
if you come work for me and we're doing
this in this
we're having a annual review on april
8th of 2022 what did you accomplish this
year what does
a plus look like and we will go back and
forth we'll redline this thing
and when we get it in a place that we're
both we're both excited about
we then use that as the benchmark for
how your performance is actually
happening in the company
so at 90 days we'll take a look at this
and we'll say hey zach
here was that a plus performance review
that we agreed upon when you came in to
to come take this job
uh you know what i actually think you're
surpassing it
great [ __ ] job you know give you like
give you uh you know
a smack you know a smack and i'll tell
you like
a high five keep going right on the flip
side
if you're like if you're like 15 below
if you're like at plan to like 15
below plan hey zach you're doing a great
job but like
there's a couple little things that i
think you can fix to get you back on
that a plus path
right now i think you're on an a minus
path or an a path
but i i want you to be an all-star here
i want you to be a hall of fame player
here's what i need you to fix sometimes
people are 15 to 30
off right and at that point you're like
hey you know what zach like i'm gonna
really need you to see
you know some improvement here otherwise
like i think we're gonna fall
short i just don't have confidence that
we're gonna make it and then
there's other people and you've hired
them on the campaign where
you know you know like by lunchtime the
first day that like
they are not the right fit right they're
they're more than 30
off the mark those are the people you
just got to fire immediately
and just say hey you know what zach
thank you so much for taking a shot on
the campaign
um this isn't gonna work out i don't
think this is the best fit for us
this is the best fit for you we're
dedicated to helping you find a place
where you can be more successful
uh but you know we're gonna have to part
ways and being maniacal about
that and being okay with making mistakes
because
look it's it's there and the other thing
i'll mention too like we take a lot of
pride in the culture that we built to
cameo
and you know we've been our culture has
become
you know famous you know we've won all
types of awards for the culture
that we have but i believe that culture
doesn't get set top down it doesn't come
from you and andrew it actually
culture is happens at a very local basis
right
if one individual team hires an [ __ ]
on it the 10 people that work with them
every day their
work just sucks more for them than it is
the culture becomes like hating the
[ __ ]
so so ultimately i believe that culture
changes
every time that you hire somebody it
either gets better or gets
worse and this is where you know you
have to look at your mission your vision
and your core values
and really be maniacal about hey here's
this person that we just brought in
are they going to help us achieve and
manifest their long-term vision and
mission and if not you got to swap them
out and find somebody else like cam
our biggest blue chip companies do not
get this right
so it's ridiculous to think like
startups or campaigns gonna get it right
no
no nobody nails it right in another
thing too that i've seen in my career
right
there are people that have done
exceptional work
in the past people i knew from you know
college
people i knew from working at other
companies with them
that sometimes they come when they're
working with you might not be the best
point of their life like they might be
going through things at home they might
may have health issues
right we're human so it's it's about
like how do you
find people that are doing the best work
of their career
and my exec my executive coach is a guy
named bing gordon
and bing um when we were when we were
talking about
last year like i i went through
rebuilding my entire executive team
during a global pandemic as we decided
to move to a fully distributed company
right so prior to that cameo was
headquartered in chicago
most the executive team was in chicago
we had a couple sprinkled in la
and we then decided to get rid of our
offices have a national search for
cfo for coo for cto for chief people
officer
and we said we don't care where you live
we just want to get the best people no
matter where you are
and and and as we were going through
this process i asked
bing i said bing when you've been around
great executive teams at amazon at
zynga electronic arts you know countless
companies
like what what causes teams to really
gel and become hall of fame
and he had this story about uh ray bork
the famous hockey player from
long time boston bruin ray bork played i
think 19 years from the bruins never won
a stanley cup
halfway through his last season they
traded him uh to the colorado avalanche
and he won the stanley cup in game seven
like on his last game and and things
said it's like i ran into
ray bork on the golf course and and and
i asked him ray what did it take to win
the stanley cup and he goes
you know you need a couple sat drizzled
old vets
that still have a blue burning flame so
they've had a hall of fame careers
but they still like are hungry for to
lift the stanley cup one more time or
or maybe they never they've had a hall
of fame career and they've never won but
like this just gives them that
blue burning flame that they've
accomplished everything but they like
need to do this and you kind of need
that veteran leadership
you then need like uh you know a few
otherworldly rookies people that are
like so talented but young dumb and
stupid and like
don't even know what they're up against
and i kind of think like the chicago
blackhawks you know
uh you know during the dynasty like
patrick kane you know
jonathan says like these guys are 19 20
years old
and they're just like in their kits
right and they're just
so good and then he's like then you need
you know two lines
of you know a players that
have are about to do the best work of
their lives
right and he's like that's the formula
for building a hall of fame team
and i think it's the same on campaigns
right i actually think
in many ways a political campaign that
gets traction
is the closest thing in the world to a
venture scale startup
right we just ingested a hundred million
dollars
and all of a sudden like you know now
it's like all right
how do we grow this thing not just in
the us but like how do we make this work
in japan
and brazil and all over the world and
like in time is money that money's in
the bank and the clock is starting
just like for a campaign you know you
guys have a huge fundraising quarter
you have to scale up operations and it
is like
you know guns blazing the differences on
a campaign eventually it just
ends right it's like oh yeah it's run
into a wall and you're really in amazon
shutting it down and shutting it down
where for us
when you're in that blitz scaling mode
you have to
make sure that you build a culture that
can
sustain and you know and it's still a
place
five years from now that people want to
come and work every day
because they love the vision the mission
and the team that you've built around
them
and also it is like it is um the
challenges of hiring people fast and
building something on the fly and
the combination of inexperience and
veterans and building and bringing
building a team and stuff
that's not an excuse for screwing up
like we like you know like we made a ton
of mistakes um
and some i like personally like regret
so that's not an excuse to screw up like
you know like
there's still responsibility to be had
you still have to build a good culture
the fight despite the odds stacked
against you still have to hire great
people
and like even though it's like in many
ways like you're you're shooting in the
dark it's like a bit of a luck game and
look here's the other thing like
there's this is not a boo-hoo
conversation look the the reality is we
knew this too like andrew
like this is the nfl or keeper sports
challenge this is the most competitive
environment in the world like you're in
a startup world like you're trailblazing
it's most competitive
in the world politics same thing maybe
more so because it's so public
um and you're gonna make mistakes you're
gonna make awesome decisions you roll
with them you learn from them you go
well even even to the nfl analogy right
uh nfl is a 52-man
roster 53-man roster and i think
training camp starts somewhere like you
know they get
about 80 people on the training camp
roster too so it's also that same like
you know 20 to you know 33 percent of
people that aren't working out
and you know you're having this trial by
fire and
there is no room on an nfl team for the
people that aren't going to help you win
games in the future right so just
because you did great work before
are you going to be able to you know
help win the next super bowl like that's
what you're optimizing for
and in both you know political campaigns
and startups i think it's the same right
it's like
you you need people that have been there
done that but
you should also be hiring for ceiling
versus resume
right and if you have a longer term
timeline which i know you guys do then
you can you can have people grow into
roles one of the hardest parts campaigns
like hey you know
you got three months here you can't grow
on the job you don't know how to do you
don't
what future cameo future this but also
like kind of the future of the
marketplace too where do you see this
going
we're really excited about the vision of
the company which is
in the future like we want to create
technology which enables
every talent to have a personalized
relationship a personal relationship
with every single one
of their supporters or fans that's
really exciting
i think it opens up a host of new
formats for us not just the personalized
video message which
you know we've become famous for but
things like our new fan club offering
uh things like cameo calls which is
synchronous video chats
uh things like cameo director or dming
product
so there's a whole ecosystem of things
that are around us
and it's all about uh you know how do we
help
people build better relationships at the
end of the day so i think that's thing
number one thing number two
26 of our traffic comes from abroad
already
and we haven't even really started
trying uh to grow the business
outside of the english-speaking world so
we have people in london and the uk
today but
you know how big could this be in korea
with k-pop or in japan or in
brazil or in you know western europe you
know all over the world i got i'm greek
and my parents my mom and her friends
are like why isn't this greek singer on
the platform it's not that we couldn't
get them it's just such a big world
that we haven't focused on that and now
this next phase for us is like
how do we even before thinking about
creating new verticals
how do we just continue to go more
horizontal and
and go from the 40 000 people we have
today to the 5 million people globally
that we think could be on this
uh as quickly as possible so that's
that's kind of what's next
well i think that's exciting it's also
talking about like democratizing
entertainment and fame and
talent certain ways like i love i love
that show
on uh on netflix or lupin if we want to
americanize it but it's like an american
it's a heist movie but it's in french
bring french entertainment to the united
states and uk entertainment and
japanese entertainment this is becoming
an international landscape instead of
just an american landscape and i hope
frankly i'm excited to see cameo play a
front center role
in that so look man congratulations on
building this
entrepreneurship i use the bamboo
analogies like bamboo takes like two
years to grow
like six inches and then it's
like two weeks to grow ten feet like the
rest of it so
uh congratulations i hope you get a
little uh
you get to smile and and enjoy the ride
um and from the bottom of my heart thank
you for your time steve
thanks zach and as i said earlier and i
mean this sincerely
this is a necessary step to building a
hall of fame company and
you know i believe we're in the top of
the second inning here and there is a
whole lot more work to do
it's very similar to a political
campaign where when you win
office right then now you the hard work
starts and you have to govern
and you want to leave this city a better
place so
uh we'll be cheering for for you guys
from the sideline as well and
you know pumped to watch what happens
this year well thank you man
let's do it
[Music]
you